a card game using 36 unique cards for
suits diamonds hearts clubs and spades
with cards numbered from 1 to 9 in each
suit so there's 4 suits each of them
have 9 cards so that gives us 36 unique
cards a hand is a collection of 9 cards
which can be sorted however the player
chooses so they're essentially telling
us that order does not matter what is
the probability of getting all four of
the ones so they want to know the
probability the probability of all of
getting all four of the one so all four
ones in my hand of nine now this is kind
of daunting at first like gee you know I
have nine cards and I'm kicking them out
of 36 I have to figure out how do I get
all of the ones but if we think about it
just very very in very simple terms all
all probability is saying is the number
of events or I guess you could say the
the number of ways in which this this
action or this event happens so this is
what the definition of the probability
is it's going to be the number of ways
in which event can happen can happen and
when we talk about the event we're
talking about having all four ones in my
hand that's the event and all of these
different ways that's sometimes called
the event space but we actually want to
count how many ways that if I get a hand
of nine picking from 36 that I can get
at that I can get the four ones in it so
is the number of ways in which my event
can happen and we want to divide that we
want to divide that into all of the
possibilities all of the or maybe I
should write it this way
the total number of hands that I can get
the total number of hands so the
numerator in blue is the number of hands
where I have or the number of different
hands where I have at where I have the
four ones and we're dividing it to
divide the total number of hands so
let's figure out the total number of
hands first because some level this
might be more intuitive and we
you've done this before now the total
number hands we're picking nine cards
and we're picking them from a set of 36
unique cards and we've done this many
many times let me write this total
number total number of hands or total
number of possible hands that's equal to
you can imagine you have nine cards to
pick from the first card you pick it's
going to be one of 36 cards then the
next one's going to be one of
thirty-five then the next one's going to
be one of 34 33 32 31 we're going to do
this 9 times 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 & 9 so that
would that would be the total number of
hands if order mattered but we know and
we've gone over this before that we
don't care about the order we all we
care about the actual cards that are in
there so we're over counting here we're
over counting for all of the different
rearrangements that these cards would
have it shouldn't it doesn't matter
whether whether the the ace of diamonds
is the first card I pick or the last
card I pick the way I've counted them
right now we are counting those as two
separate hands but they aren't two
separate hands since so order doesn't
matter so what we have to do is we have
to divide this we have to divide this by
the wood number of ways you can arrange
nine things so you could put nine of the
things in the first position then eight
in the second seven and the third so
forth and so on it's essentially becomes
nine factorial times two times one and
we've seen this multiple times this is
essentially 36 choose nine this
expression right here is the same thing
just so you can relate it to the the I
guess combinatorics formulas that you
might be familiar with this is the same
thing as 36 factorial over 36 minus 9
factorial that's what this orange part
is over here divided by 9 factorial or
over 9 factorial what's green is what's
green and what is orange is what's
Orange there so that's the total number
of hands now a little bit more of a
nuanced thought process is how do we
figure out the number of ways in which
the event can happen which we can get
have all four ones so let's figure that
out so number of ways or maybe we should
say this number of
hands with with four ones
with four ones and just as a little bit
of thought experiment imagine if we were
only picking four cards if I hand only
had four cards in it well if a card only
had four hands if a hand only had four
cards in it then the only the number of
ways to get a hand with for once there's
only be there only be one way one
combination you just have four ones
that's the only combination with four
ones if we were only picking four cards
but here we're not only picking four
cards there's one four of the cards are
going to be are going to be ones so four
of the cards are going to be ones let me
one two three four but the other five
cards are going to be different so one
two three four five so for the other
five cards for the other five cards if
you imagine this slot considering that
of the thirty six we've already we would
have we would have to pick four of them
already
in order for us to be have four ones so
there's another if there's well we've
used up four of them so there's 32
possible cards over in that position of
the hand and then there'd be thirty one
in that position of the hand and then
there'd be 30 because every time we're
picking a card we're using it up and now
we only have thirty to pick from then we
only have twenty twenty-nine to pick
from and then we have twenty eight to
pick from and just like we did before we
don't care about order we don't care if
we find that if we pick the five of
clubs first or whether we pick the five
of clubs last so we shouldn't double
count it so we have to divide by the
different number of ways that five cards
can be arranged so we have to divide
this we have to divide this by the
different ways that five cards can be
arranged so the first card or the first
position could be any one of five cards
then four cards then three cards then
two cards than one cards so the number
of hands with four ones is actually is
actually just this number you're
actually looking at all of the different
ways you can fill up the remaining cards
these four ones are just going to be
four ones there's only one way to get
that it's the remaining cards that's
going to give all of the different
combinations of having four ones so this
will be a count of all of the different
combinations because all of the
extra stuff that you have will be all of
the different hands now we know the
total number of hands with four ones is
this number and now we can divide it by
the total number of possible hands and I
didn't multiply them out on purpose so
that we can cancel things out so let's
do that let's take this and divide by
that so let me just copy and paste it
let me take that let me copy it and let
me paste it let's take that and let's
divide it by let's divide it by that but
dividing by a fraction is the same thing
as multiplying by the reciprocal so
let's just multiply by the reciprocal so
let's multiply so this is the
denominator let's make this the
numerator so let me copy it and then let
me paste it so that's the numerator and
then that's the denominator up there
because we're dividing by that
expression so let me let me have to
whoops let me put that there let me get
the Select tool and then let make sure
I'm selecting all of the numbers let me
copy it and then let me paste that it's
a little messy with those lines there
but I think this will suit our purposes
this will suit our purposes just fine so
when we're multiplying by this we're
essentially dividing by this expression
up here now this we can simplify pretty
easily we have a we have a well actually
I forgot to do this is this should be
nine factorial this should be 9 times 8
times 7 times 6 times 5 times 4 times 3
times 2 times 1 so let me put that in
both places actually let me just let me
let me clear that both places clear
don't confuse people clear I'm sorry if
that confused you when I wrote it
earlier this would be 9 factorial 9
times 8 times 7 times 6 times 5 times 4
times 3 times 2 times 1 let me copy and
paste that now copy and then you paste
it that's that right there and then we
have this in the numerator we have 5
times 4 times 3 times 1 in the
denominator so this will cancel out with
that part right over there
and then we have 32 times 31 times 30
times 29 times 28 that is going to
cancel with that that and that cancels
out so what we're left with is just this
part over here let me rewrite it so
we're left with 9 times 8 times 7 times
6 over over and this will just be a
exercise in simplifying this expression
36 times 35 times 34 times 33 and let's
see if we divide the numerator
denominator by 9 that becomes a 1 this
becomes a 4 you can divide the numerator
denominator by 4 this becomes a 2 this
becomes a 1 you divide numerator and the
denominator by 7 this becomes a 1 this
becomes a 5 you can divide both by 2
again and then this becomes a 1 this
becomes a 17 and you could divide this
and this by 3 this becomes a 2 and then
this becomes an 11 so we're left with
the probability of having all four ones
in my hand of 9 that I'm selecting from
36 unique cards is equal to in the
numerator I'm just left with this 2
times 1 times 1 times 1 so it's equal to
2 over 5 times 17 times 11 and that is
so any drum roll this was kind of an
involved problem 5 times 17 times 11 is
equal to 935 so it's equal to 2 over 935
so about roughly 2 and a thousand chance
or one in a 500 roughly speaking this is
the exact odds you have roughly 1 in 500
chance of getting all four of the ones
in your hand of nine when you're
selecting from 36 unique cards